hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now we just
gotta ejected out into space which is
usually not good for people's health but
I may not be a people anyway so let's
get out of here or wherever the hell we
are
I have a funny feeling oh all of my
fears have been confirmed hi this is
chief Ellis ala the airlocks on Talos
are sealed but there's an opening at the
cargo bay you could use I think you can
get back inside the station here okay
alrighty then
oh ok I was wondering where I was I'm
way way way up the tower right now so I
can only assume that I need to go where
it says multiple objectives because I'm
not seeing any corpses but there's also
a whole bunch of other things here she
said that I need to go to the cargo bay
and what I gotta do is I gotta uncheck
some of these things because I need to
get out of here whoa what is that far I
could regain access to that area Oh
oooh I could probably do that I know how
to do that I could do that but what I
need to do is I need to get rid of these
things like I don't need this how do I
undo that uh set inactive there we go
and then whistleblower maybe but for
right now Oh Leidner oh I need that one
so I need to get rid of that one I know
I need to get to the lift and I know how
to do that but I will get there soon so
I need to get to the cargo bay to
continue the story and I still need to
get Alex's key because I do want to do
that but because the breach is right
there I'm gonna go for that next and
zippity-doo-dah my way through space
because what a wonderful place it is and
I'm assuming I'm just assuming I can do
this with glue my sweet tasty glue then
I'm gonna splatter all over there and
hopefully that's gonna solve the
problems maybe
hi hi buddy are you that guy that was
really giving me a whole bunch of
adjectives before because you're a giant
prick yeah you are aren't you
hi hello now it's marking time I've been
wondering if it might be bothering you
that you planned your own death mm-hmm
it's a lot to swallow
my advice would be try not to think
about the end focus on what's in front
of you one step at a time
wait plan much if you need help well
where I'm I'm a little wait hang out of
it plan my own death wait we mean by
that what are you talking about plan my
own death in in what capacity here in
what weird world did I plan my own death
you want to run that by me one more time
there big guy I'm gonna be able to kill
this guy soon you should right yeah yeah
ain't got do nothing all no you blasted
I can do that too you know but I miss I
oh hi okay excuse you I'm gonna get you
boink
oh no you're all kinds of dead are you
oh he exploded okay so he's dead now I'm
gonna go try to chase down his giblets
cuz those are valuable hey hey hey hey
okay just a whole bunch of Typhon organ
i mean it's not like i need all them I'm
a qualified engineer oh I'm not gonna
repair you I'm not gonna waste my spare
parts oh all right then
- magically appeared there there we go
there we go alright alright so we did
that for some reason the glue is able to
hold that this stuff is magical
I mean bash it with a hammer and it's
all gone but I guess that's a moot point
in comparison to everything else so if
I'm not mistaken
I've already looted this guy and needy
do I have so let's uh let's get a handle
down to the cargo bay because we've
already been in this area and we've
already got people looking at me funny
actually I can do this with the glue gun
can i or I can just do this if you would
not run away from me like a little baby
oh how many of you are there
is there a weaver in there I'm
broadcasting to all contacts in
proximity please whoever is out accident
in cargo bay possibly to seal myself
inside this container but I have no I
could talk with the station from here
wait so where are you
it said he was in here somehow but where
oh okay
alright they popped with this stuff so I
guess that's good
yeesh all right so where was that that's
timely oh where where where is that I
don't know where that is uh okay let me
turn off everything except for that one
because he's about to die all right
where is he where is he where is he
where where where where where am I
looking at I can't see it goddamned oh
here we go oh really wow that's amazing
actually
the hell did you manage to do that
excuse me I know your life is in danger
and all but I got to collect this
[ __ ] over here hello ah pretty oh
you were saying you were dying oh okay
hello you have no space suits so I can't
just open this right I have to get him a
space suit that's the thing right if I
open this if I just open it
wouldn't he die question mark wouldn't
he just die see ah I can enter that
number at the docking terminal oh ah
okay so what I got to do not open it
because if I hacked that and open it he
would be very dead I have to enter that
in the docking terminal to return him
safely in Talos okay so that's over
there okay easy peasy well this isn't
hard at all why would anyone not do this
if there's leave them to his fate out
there they must be an alien of some kind
skadoosh key skip loose key oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa where why what and how to
get inside there's not an airlock
anymore that explosion took care of that
yeah maybe you can do something with the
shipping containers maybe I could do
something with the shipping containers
oh god damn it
better cool attention Jesus I'm all I'm
out of I'm out of med kits I never
thought that would happen but I'm out of
med kits okay so what was the number it
was it was two three one two okay so if
I hit two three one two okay uh not open
it docket docket and then open it
because if I did that in the wrong order
again he would die I heard will do my
life so maybe if I dock him in there
I'll dock him in there Oh last I thought
that crate would be my coffee huh even
the stale air of Tullis laced with a
faint hint of nicotine and
antibacterials oh he's like spring yeah
my thanks doc to you but I thought well
you're no longer running the memory
hamster wheel I see I hope you're coming
in after me would be good to see a
familiar face might be and transmitting
the code to the crate I was eating okay
ah I know what that is
okay so what I gotta do is I gotta bring
it out way huh he worked in the
simulation lab and in psychotronics he
might be helpful but he's unlikely to
approve of your mission despite
everything he suffered though I will
note he's always admired you and Alex
quite a bit
uh-huh so if I open it which I believe I
just did right if I open it up then I
can get inside but how am I gonna be
able to how am I gonna how am I gonna
dock this thing oh wait no yeah no yeah
that's the question that I have right
now cuz there's there's some there's
fundamental math problems that don't
seem to be adding up here oh maybe it's
got two entrances oh come back baby come
back you can blame it all on me you can
blame it all on me you can ah you can
you can blame it all on me
okay oh I need to do anything of that I
was just a big dumb doof ah I was very
dumb I thought that I needed to
different thing with that the thing in
the a you know how it is okay alright
then everyone's gonna laugh am you know
alright so now that I'm in here is
equate gonna be alive or is he gonna be
a steaming Corp Shh
cuz that always seems to be a
possibility EGH wa e go oh hi hi hello
Austin cool what are you doing up there
well I mean alright but doctor you Oh
Morgan
yeah just sure officer cool if we can't
open the main door or our friends are
gonna pour through get up to the catwalk
we'll get you inside okay alright is he
go up there too there seem to be a lot
of zoombies on here I don't want to call
Tom B's but you know oh you didn't see
nothing were you talking about hey
friend I'm just gonna have to glue you
cuz I don't feel like fighting you're
too hard
I feel like fighting you a little bit
but not too hard when we get all the
materials first I should be a lot more
stealthy about this usually anyway ow
why'd you have to do that I'm out of
health kicks get deuce what ah okay so
if I can repair Oh
I thought I could repair it in time I
thought I don't know why I thought I
could repair it in time but that was a
big dumb doofy thing for me to do but
okay so take two on that one I'm gonna
stealth this time and try to be a little
less obvious about my movements here as
I sprint immediately I say I'm gonna be
quiet and then immediately mr.
jibber-jabber and all over the place
okay stupid to do stupid to do oh I
can't go up there rip we're all really
yeah that little knob is gonna get me I
didn't even need to use the glue did I
because I could oh I can't do anything
parent hop there we go all right so now
I'm gonna stealth I'm gonna be a little
bit better about this and I'm gonna make
my way to those turrets because that is
what I need immediately now if I had
some sort of remote manipulation who'd
have thought about that then I'd be able
to do those hello we have a rogue one er
is that a good one you're good or bad I
can never tell or whatever I'm gonna
assume that it's bad until proven
otherwise and check out this corpse okay
at a wrench okay that sounds good yeah
hey buddy what are you doing up there
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey
so what you're doing Oh ran right into
the raging fire and so I can't quite go
all the way up there to reach him but I
can not too much fire yeah it's not
gonna be able to hold that down oh man
that looks dangerous oh but I made it
around Oh barely
okay boom man these guys just lit on
fire didn't they all right
Oh med kit thank you very much this
guy's literally just on fire
locked out until I update my credentials
how about reply or reply or won't forget
that anytime soon okay
reply or require it is alright good
thing you wrote it down okay let's go
doodly-doo Italy do haha alright so I
still got to get up and I still got to
get over there but at least I'm away
from the media oh yeah you don't report
anybody I know you guys don't actually
report to each other but still just feel
like it you did good okay what is that
oh I turned power on I didn't even know
it was off judging by the giant Jets of
flame I assumed that was the power so
stupid of me okay
turn this off sneaky sneaky sneaky
sneaky I don't know what the wig
webbie's is but I'm gonna assume it's
not important to me I could go up there
I think I might be okay I'm gonna make
it in there without any trouble because
I'm going to set off distractions
oh okay oh oh no oh no not worth not not
not what I wanted not what I wanted the
opposite of what I wanted oh that's
nothing that's not the pattern I had
looked for Rick oh oh no oh good Oh
Morgan I'm almost up here oh God no we
can't open the main door or our friends
are gonna pull we're free I had one
flight look good look at all this food
officers collected those oh is there
mark for you oh sorry sorry sorry I had
reached the power supply in time I'm
gonna eat all this food in front of you
again sorry it's I I'm very hungry I got
a lot of aliens inside of me that need
feeding leg immediately and don't mind
all the tumors and whatnot I'm carrying
ganglia all right sorry sorry Ekaterina
I thought I don't know what I thought
it's good to see you
it's Transtar mounting a rescue
operation you got me you got me by the
sorcery storage when when the fire broke
out and everyone began running but they
weren't running from the fire it was
these shapes
I had contained the fire and I was
trying to reach the power supply when al
officer Rose came and got me out I'm
glad he did I didn't know what was going
on or anything about those things
everyone I worked with they're dead
aren't they
I wonder if one of the creatures caused
the explosion and fuel storage are they
intelligent do they plan this yeah I
heard all the escape pods malfunctioned
all of them how is that possible uh
again you've got a lot of questions and
I don't got a lot of answers here so I'm
just I'm I'm just as lost as you are so
cut me a slack I guess working aboard a
space station like Talos is comparable
to working on earth oh wait I already
knew about
never at that when a while ago did
LeDoux star bender some novel they're
not important for me at the moment
sadface the deliverer shovel arrived
earlier with chlorine trifluoride aboard
it has been offloaded and awaits you in
cargo bay a I need everyone involved
with the transfer to review procedures
and protocols at the start of their
shift today as you will be lucky
individuals that could escort these
contents to fuel storage I don't think I
need to remind you that chlorine
trifluoride will do if you mishandle it
to SAS key knock stick to procedures and
everything will be fine once it's
secured I'll give you all the rest of
the shift off Oh sad face II was
assigned to your era temporarily I've
encouraged him to stay out of your way
and avoid interacting with cargo bay
personnel so why is he here and why was
he ejected in his in a literally just a
cargo container all by himself I have no
idea anyway there was something else
here narrow there was not who wait was
there something else here huh a wrench
that's what blown at me in this note
okay
detail of accident accident during fuel
transfer blast walls held now the blast
doors closing dansby's contained not
power has been knocked out
can't get resources everyone is tied up
I don't know why I'm filing this except
I don't know what to do at this point
ah this is after the emergency and it's
just someone being desperate no key well
again I want to thank you for the timely
rescue you're welcome I hope you recall
me dr. gray died Oh
EGH way your brother Alex brought me to
the station
to head up neuroma tree search mm-hmm
have one but no aptitude template saving
it but well now might be best yeah I'm
sure you could make better use of it oh
[Music]
oh a hypo fabrication playing the tuner
Oh mods okay that's all the reward I get
for doing the arduous task of Maria yeah
but chips it's mike with Librium i need
to steady myself after the slow roll of
the crate I could feel it
turning you know my stomach along with
it closest I've ever come to vertical
and claustrophobia oh you're a mode that
could cure that maybe yeah everything is
solved by neuroma
am i all right are you all right can't
even talk to you anymore
I mean I'm part alien but that's you
know a whole nother problem that I got
in me who else is here oh my god this
blob watching those things move it makes
me sick hmm have you stayed there you
might have survived longer than any what
is it doing oh my god did it I think I'm
gonna be sick
oh I missed it it's really normal things
like you pulled it right out of Enochs
corpse huh corpse maybe I don't know
maybe it saved him you could still be
inna does it look like it Sam
promise me you'll kill me if I ever end
up like that you Sara will get us out of
this she got us this far we're safe in
here good now don't say that I'm going
to check the perimeter there there's a
mindful person but are you gonna go
alone Alfred Rose hello I died please
throw me out of an airlock burn me but
don't let them make me into one of them
okay this seems a lot sensational here I
thought that maybe we could just have a
fun chat about you know not dying which
is always cool I guess you know Ray were
the survivors Oh mister that's a mist
over there can be a Democrat all right
whatever I guess you can't be blamed he
just saw his friends get turned into
horrible mush monsters and now I'm gonna
talk to this infamous Sarah hello a good
evening I'll take the Hickok take these
I'll talk with you in one moment after
I'm done looting all of your valuables
of lies mm yes don't you know I run this
place with my brother who hates me I'm
an alien - don't mind me please relay
the following to the security crew at
this next staff meeting earthside
present very good appraisal of our
provisioning and cargo staff during LAN
LAN village about the board rigors
Dallas cargoes have performed admirably
during the inspection well done keep up
the good work okay thank you will be dr.
Eid way figures he'd survive dumb luck I
suppose oh geez you can't be happy that
another person survived
oh no this this human didn't die
horribly
you are just it's alright yeah okay
really a lot of love for your phone find
a way out of here
take dr. eat way so you came all this
way only to get back into Talos yes only
way in is through the door to cargo baby
which is filled with those creatures
that your brother insisted couldn't
escape confinement yes kind of like you
yes I'm the only one with the code it's
yours if you can help us secure the
firepower we should have had when
assigned here the Eradicator turret
fabrication plan then my men told me
powers been restored to the fabricator
that was you wasn't it I was quick to
underestimate you doctor hey all we need
is the turret fabricator plan yeah
there's one in the safe in the Security
office but the hull breach puts it out
of my reach still if you have a suit and
are up for another walk we could really
use the additional firepower look I
don't know what you're planning Morgan
but just remember the only thing that
matters is how you treat the people that
are still alive I mean I guess my alien
friends ain't alive and they ain't
exactly my friend either but you know
they're there they're there
easy and I like that maybe it's the
Eradicator fabrication plan we want not
the reply or plan whatever the hello rip
lawyer is yeah I don't know what a reply
er is anyway besides that guy's password
because he's an idiot and he wrote it
down okay so I need to know we're in
something right doctor equate is lucky
to be here or not uh I'd have been safer
and it's great
yeah maybe might've been okay so woo
what did I see just run by there and
there's a corpse but what did I see just
run by there oh hi oh hey how's it going
there hey Heidi Heidi Heidi oh you don't
seem violent at all okay you just stay
over there I can't scan that one all
right I'm on a skedaddle it oh this one
is broken too so I got to get out there
again I gotta do something about all
this hello who are you again smoke was a
medical operator uh night you look like
you need a plastic surgeon operator
Jesus and soul meal and soul you write
back our Player Award last it was
fortunate you came along when he did
yeah mr. McGill as a safety precaution
we have disabled critical machinery
required to open the exterior door in
cargo bay B and as an added insurance
the door has been welded shut that Bay's
for storage only then we want to be
certain there can be no accidental
opening restoring the bay door to full
function will be practically impossible
isn't that the door than any air that's
the door than I need to go through is
okay all right then um Anders got your
message about the shipment failure i
dispatched an engineering operator to
check it out and something weird
happened thirteen oh wow God you make me
[ __ ] startled B what did feel like it
was whispering in my ear you freaking
[ __ ] fine all right the readings were
unlike anything we've ever seen side
effect from the psychotronics project in
any case the operator was able to move
through it and investigate but shortly
after it became unresponsive I'm gonna
have to get human eyes on it but all of
our people are tied up with a critical
fuel transfer when that's done I'll send
someone to check it out
Thanks there was a blast in cargo bay
exterior doors ruptured oh this is
floating or drift over the chlorine
trifluoride container and detonate oh
that's no good wait a minute are they
talking about are they talking about the
Typhon or someone with Typhon neural
mods installed they can do such a
devious thing hmm all right I don't like
it though something seems fishy here and
I ain't all about it oh yeah okay that's
lockdown you all right no I'm not all
right why would I be all right Austin
dealing with the Eradicator x' would be
a lot better than these cap guns
Transtar sign this
okay alright so I gotta get outside and
I gotta get this plan because number one
this plane is gonna be fast our PBM
pistols are mostly for show they don't
do much against the attackers with the
Eradicator turrets have a chance okay I
get it I get it but I can't get through
here because apparently it's been welded
short and also there's a ton of monsters
out there so I need to go the long way
around probably and I need to get uh I
need to get out so okay I see where I
need to go okay so I need to go outside
I'm gonna set up the turrets that are
already out there because there's a
salvager and there's a repair system out
there any way that I can dabble with and
hopefully they're gonna be able to get
me what I need okay so I'm gonna wait
until this guy patrols the other way I'm
gonna try to repair that turret stand
behind that barricade and then I should
be okay for the immediate future because
those turrets should be able to take him
down yeah
these guys look less and friendly less
and friendly I could also use my mimic
ability if I had something worth
mimicking I'd probably take there be
this tiny box please be this tiny box
please tell me I can beat this tank back
yeah did you see that over there to
freak you out lady whoa ow no one will
suspect this tiny box but it eluded you
that it did did you do that okay
blow okay sneaky sneaky peeky repair and
it's up and running so next time that
guy comes by I should be good to go
take another one of these bed looks for
work okay so now that we got that nuts
not what I wanted that's not what I
wanted out of you blow get them where is
it oh that's too far
what that's not fair at all at least it
was a distraction Jesus okay oh I don't
want to have to repair it again but I
guess I gotta all right well that did me
no good at all these guys over Oh miss
be cool come on ocean that didn't go as
planned
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa did you get shot
yet how would Drizzt churching freaking
useless
get blasted in the next century by I
ouch
jeez the turrets are freakin useless oh
my god are you kidding me there's no
point in having a turret if it's is
gonna be a bunch of douche I'll give a
one last try but that's the last spare
part I'm gonna dedicate to this sumbitch
because it is not paying back dividends
all right let's recycle our [ __ ]
anyway so charity boob
dude stressful stressful very stressful
very very stressful so there we go I
need to get oh I need to make that well
I got that now so that's good
arming key I still don't know if I want
to use if at least I got it because it
was necessary the motorcyclist urge
yeesh yeah okay I get it it's really
important doodlee doodlee doodlee do
yeah I get it I get it I get it I get
very important okay so if I can lead
that lightning one so it's way over
there
hey buddy I got a hundreds bolt with
your name on it going squeaky-clean key
link Oh hurt you real boy you'd look at
me and don't look at my goddamn turret
that's all I'm asking oh there's another
one up there is there another one up
there you want to fight though Oh give
you a plate all right oh I'll give you a
fight okay he doesn't want to fight
apparently so I'm just gonna go straight
over for the fabrication plan which
means I got a skedaddle out of here
one's mirror
Juan's mirror and I'll just raise them
all you literally do no raise all one's
broken up
ah you keep doing that oh ah so close
come on yet dosha gotta go this way
again crew it okay I believe I can make
that jump hope okay there we go so now I
just need to head out and I need to get
this fabrication plan and then get back
in
give them the turrets and then hopefully
they're gonna survive because apparently
that's important for me I don't know if
I'm going to end up choosing to blow
them up because everything must die
apparently for some reason I don't know
why but that is the puritanical way of
going about this this is gonna be like a
massive back three deal where there's
some unity option as well probably okay
the fabrication plan is in there
thinkety to get a long way around to be
able to get there though we release
goodly do don't mind me take some
Huntress bolts yet by a stir oh there's
a full-on weaver in there isn't there
alright well that's a that poses a
significant problem but yo boy I had
material here there was something here
oh they're just Malone
oh no oh look at me I'm just a sweet and
it's in the booby come on
oh I didn't think that through and think
that arose didn't think that through oh
boy what huntress bolts up
okay so didn't think that one through oh
man I'm running out of sigh hypos whoa
alright let me at least blew him up whoa
okay you know what you get glued up oh
boy you all get glued up Frick oh that's
that's less than good on me let's just
get that point okay so this Weaver is
just going to be a giant sack of [ __ ]
isn't it freaking [ __ ] glad that guy
few of them
I don't even know if is gonna do
anything to the Weaver but it's frankly
all I got this juncture in time okay
that seemed to do absolutely dick
doodlee on him yeah ain't doing nothing
to him okay all right that's that's less
than nothing actually that's that's just
putting me in danger because there's now
a bajillion of these things okay all
right we didn't think this through
didn't think this through huh oh boy oh
boy ow okay that's that's though if I'm
gonna die I can't seem to move holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay I'm gonna da
boy oh I've got his EMP charges oh I
could have Typhon lured him away oh boy
is this hurting him at all no I didn't
hurt him at all
so wait hang on what could I use no wave
transmitter let's try this bad boy Oh
so whenever I break that thing shield it
gets real pissy about life ah so then it
shields down okay and then I can hit it
it's really weak when the shields down
okay I wasn't a hundred percent about
that before but now I know that now I
know who I am low on supplies I'm way
way way loans give me this thing yes
please I've got so many alien materials
now if only I had the ability
oh it ate one now if only I had the
ability to do what I need
get the neuro mods I mean you found the
Eradicator schematic yes I did we'd had
those turrets earlier oh yeah again with
you schematics half the battle once
they're built though I can't wait to see
what uh-huh okay sorry miss that
conversation because I got the
understanding of it so we got that so
I'm gonna bring this back she said
something else about half the battle
which means there's probably something
else and I'm gonna have to get because
I'm the errand boy around here oh they
can't shove needles in their eyes and
become superhuman oh it's all gonna be
about me okay so what other objective
was there was that something open oh
wait no I'm good no I'm good I'm good
I'm good I'm good I think I'm good hope
I think I'm good because they're gonna
open it from their side because it just
said they did they didn't want to open
it it'll make any more material that I
have here cuz I am whoa
yeah I can't salvage that that would
probably be a smarty smoo all right and
then I need two spare parts that seems
to go here we need two auto organized
we're good on that front and then
everything else is a-okay in my book I
also need to use this more that's it
that's another thing I have that I just
haven't used it a lot so I'm gonna use
that
someone said in the comments that that
can be used to stun the mind controlled
one so that it doesn't necessarily blow
up all over me which would be kind of
nice so I'm gonna replace that with hi
there we go
so Huntress bold is out and I'm gonna
try the stun gun because I've got a lot
of this Hey hey Austin I've got the
thing for you can yo
dip ping-pong all right fine then I'll
go upstairs like a goof why are you
making me do this
Austin I thought you were cool oh you're
pretty cool but whatever oh oh yeah
there's my lift so I remember I was
doing this in a screaming panic but okay
whatever it's good evilly do it's gonna
delete it anybody want to get tased
skadoodle II do no not today
oh we're Sarah Sarah tears her success
care of Sarah
oh oh there's her I don't know what you
want from me Sarah seems pretty easy
open case line F engage to
oh okay then well this if it was as easy
as that I would have done it a long time
ago oh yes please oh yes please take
that take that
ooh turret hey you had a turret right
here why didn't you freaking use it yet
goof yeah goof I fine I'm gonna deploy
this though
skinny husky uh yeah all righty then ooh
also someone said I could do a neat
trick here let me see if I can find
something appropriate sized you'll see
what I'm doing in just a second huh
this'll be perfect so if I take this
apparently if I take this drop booth
welp if I don't do that to it that's
another way to go about it if I take
this and don't frickin break this
antique son of a [ __ ] I just yeah okay
and then and then I just take this bad
boy and I roll it ah no no no it's so
close
ah gosh darn it oh no maybe I could find
something smaller I can probably find
something smaller but that's the
principle idea there you uh
you sneak your way in there by becoming
a tiny itty bitty mean hello Eddie
hidey-hidey-ho neighbor II know II knock
oh that's that was Enoch over there all
right okay then let me try this bad boy
if this doesn't work I'll give up cuz I
only try it twice tell me twice try mark
skadoosh skinnies
uh come on come on oh it's right there
ah I ran out of stuff we tried one more
time try one more time and that's gonna
be yet because the moon maybe I can
slide under here oh yeah baby oh just as
easy as that now getting back out might
be a bit more of a pain but I'm in here
now so that's that's a thing that I
haven't am do you like I didn't bring it
in with me did I I didn't do gay alright
mmm this is a problem here I can't oh
boy
what what Oh what did I do
Wow
excuse you what did you do what did I do
to you I just morphed into a goddamn tea
kettle oh you son of a beyotch okay I
better not be stuck in here because
those [ __ ] hit me again I'm gonna be
I'm the pair of my head maybe how'd you
see that how did you see that that's a
son of a battle biscuit bonger move
that's a biscuit bunker move I ever saw
one
yeah they're freaking out like that
other guy will Mitchell did but I didn't
you didn't see nothing oh hey
nonetheless
okay so what is the actual objective
that I need to do I know I have tons of
neural mods by the way I am aware of
that fact to you that or I get hurt some
turrets so I gotta make some hmm we're
gonna make some I don't even know where
it's her go she was here like she was
here oh hi again that's crazy okay she
was here but we're all right I'm only
assuming that they need me to make a
bunch of turrets and thankfully I have a
turret outside that is all 100% good so
maybe maybe just maybe if I get that one
they'll be happy about that
so I'll be right back I don't know if
there's gonna work at all but here we go
I guess oh oh are you kidding me I had
to place him in the loading zone oh no
you did not oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no not me
no no that's bad okay all right then
all right then sure I will just go with
that one ah hey ladies are online and
primed can't wait until our friends get
the taste of these uh-huh
here's the code for cargo baby okay oh I
gotta do it oh and now I gotta do it I
am the ultimate errand boy I will even
open the door for you okay all right huh
five nine and three I don't know what a
zero is but here we go
Julie do you Dooley to get enough Rick
out of the way screwed leader let me
scan him whoa okay they weren't ready
for this wall they were not ready for
that but the old I have no what but
they're all dead they're all dead
they're all dead
those ineffective is [ __ ] with the brick
you piece of [ __ ] those the most
ineffective thing I've ever seen oh my
god get quick look at that I've got any
worse you lost everybody
you lost everybody
oh yeah even your dad no no okay no I'm
gonna I'm gonna try that again
this time I might try to lead the fire
away cuz that that is that was not
that's not that's not how that should
have been that should have been way
better than that that should have been
Oh what happened but weren't good that
for shirking sure oh my god
they all just bit the dust yeah I'm
gonna put these like right up here so at
least the firsts from the from the
length the Haley damages they're gonna
do is gonna be intervened like here
sneezes thought that was gonna be like a
really fun excursion into shooty shooty
town and apparently it was just Bethy
Bethy junction alright and then I'm
gonna go run out there and I'm gonna
dance around like an idiot how's that
I'm also gonna do that
Wow hunched hey oh ha ha now no one is
dead apparently I got in a job that we
are secure here we can hold out
indefinitely indefinitely send other
survivors here I will protect them in in
def indefinitely do you know the words
you definitely mean and I'm still
breathing we're still breathing
sure okay alright that I need a
cigarette if you ever want it to work
with my team when we get off this
deathtrap
I'd consider it
you'd have to report to me though and
I'm not as friendly as it may seem no I
didn't pick up on that either so okay
you know what you have a lovely day I'm
just gonna keep going here for shrine
okay go surprise no one caught on to
that whenever I was talking about before
but apparently it's all okay because I
am I am pretty cool dude if you ask me
anyway so I need to are you gonna be
able to open this long with that came
from what do you mean more than with
that came from that doesn't make any
sense
I find whatever I am gonna go and
salvage all this stuff because I just
got a boatload of it yep
I'm gonna go salvage this my holy [ __ ]
yeah you guys didn't see nearly as much
as me getting lost as I thought I was
but that was a that's a bit of a that's
a bit of a you know that's a bit of a
cuz there was nothing in the description
when I looked in the objective menu
there was nothing that even said that I
needed to do specifically that set of
requirements so that's my only problem
with it is it didn't specifically say
that I needed to put them in the loading
zone which is just a little bit it's
just a little bit you know it's a little
douchey
what you would call bushi yeah I don't
want to be a burden about it but just a
little douchey well Gucci all over a
mocha but either way I got what I needed
to get now I can skedaddle out to cargo
B and then carry on behind me
thought we were dead for sure no I'm
here I'm a savior I'm an alien Savior
I'm gonna save the aliens what i'ma do
parent links let's go to Scalia pressure
all right what else you got for me
hello Oh dead body okay neuro Mon thank
you thank you very much else we got here
nothing looks like some might be up here
MA climb and skedaddle ooh it's good
Italy whoo ah this is if I wanted to be
a non-cooperative uh nass hole and
actually just you know go on my own way
all right fine but the self-destruct key
is apparently through here which is a
weird place to be okay hello oh ah so
we're in the guts loading bay which is
the opposite of where I wanted to be
originally but it is where I am so let
me just sneaky peeky over here and see
what's going on over here
I can act this nope oh wait yeah I can
hack it that was just a number for the
cut whoa okay gotta go through terror
Junction oh no oh boy oh boy oh boy
there we go X yeah I know the other way
now scoodle it it only Doolittle do
okay um and now what's in here there
better be something good
oh it's part of the whistle oh well that
sounded ominous and good gently okay cue
I can't thank you enough for the risk
you're taking on my behalf on behalf of
the volunteers who no longer have a
voice in this the thought of you cooped
up in that cargo container hurtling
towards the earth it kills me even
though will says it's safe and that
you'll have plenty of food I know the
evidence on this thumb drive cannot make
amends for everything that's happened
but exposing the truth can prevent it
from happening again thank you my friend
how would he be safe in a cargo
container hurtling towards Earth I don't
think that's a good idea but okay he had
plenty of food but how did he die then
how did he die what the drive in your
possession contains incriminating
evidence related to illegal experiments
performed aboard Talos one in the
psychotronics lab these includes
classified internal memorandums key
research today two spanning several
decades names and roles of all personnel
involved volunteer IDs matched with
their real names
this information will corroborate the
existence of an extraterrestrial species
called Python as well as the fact that
all neuro mods are made at the expense
of human victims I harbor no illusion
that this will be easy to believe but I
can testify to its veracity assuming I'm
still alive because I was the
participant in many of the experience
experiments referenced okay Quinton
alrighty then why did I do that I mean
he was dead anyway so I wasn't exactly
going anywhere so what was the point at
least I have it maybe is like leverage
against Alex you know cuz whatever good
that is okay so that guy is blocking my
path almost directly so I gotta try to
find a sneaky way around he's not gonna
be able to detect Oh what was that
someone whispering inside my skull my
being possessed a demon's probably
probably hatee-hatee-hatee-ho neighbor
yeah you keep zip tapping up there I'm
gonna stay down here and look over oh
this is the under way good thing he's
listening to incredible dubstep all he's
existing all right I don't see a way
around him looks like I'm gonna have to
fight this [ __ ] alright at least I
can get the drop on him with a sweet
shot he gonna hear you
wait what but he wasn't he wasn't
aggressive did you guys see that that's
why I stopped shooting I didn't shoot
just to die he stopped being aggressive
why what you want
oh god I'm all the way back here oh no
I'm right here
what
[Music]
why is he not
that's super weird
what why though I don't understand that
hi what
but he's just not what huh right okay I
don't know I don't know what that was
all about I don't know what the hell was
going on that's so weird
why was he not attacking me uh no idea I
have no idea I honestly have no idea why
he wasn't acting me crazy
anyway crazier things have been done
would that can do I see you got your
transcribe for his making his way to you
now or anything huh mihaela didn't think
to check your transcribe not sure how he
got here I told you left because never
might air locks and lifts are locked up
like my lungs para plexus I'm even
seeing the spots now you're right even
if I could get my booster shots from my
office but I think I can get us out by
cycling the main reactors to bypass the
laptop I know it sounds crazy but I can
walk you through it I do it myself but
I'll just get here alright okay alright
are you the person that I broke up with
in that email win the beginning of the
goddamn game are you that's so weird I
it's hard to tie names to voices these
days but reboot access the controller
room with this ring treasure hunt copy
protections I need to do that I have to
do that eventually because I just
there's no other way the only place to
get there is from Talos lobby in the
neuro mods division I got to go back
there eventually
where am I even now I'm in the power
plant how the hell did I know I'm not in
the power plant
where am I am I in the neuroma division
right now no I'm not
where am I oh I'm in life support that's
where I am okay so if there's a way to
get back to Dallas one I gotta get there
it's good to get a little it's good
Italy Italy okay what would be the best
way to approach this
probably to skate right by skier leading
lady
you lead oh you didn't see nothing
yeah I see a turret though Oh surprise
[ __ ] whoa where'd you go
all right cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool
I think this is the way back actually
which means I can get back to the lobby
which means I can go to the neuro mad
lab the lab it and then hopefully
[Applause]
okay I don't know what you're talking
about but I was probably the same thing
that you've always been talking about
fires raging the bodies everywhere
fun fun fun do not share with Webber LS
security booth safe code well that's
handy good thing these people died right
outside the safe that I probably needed
in oh this person dead bad ish there's a
maintenance panel here all right I'm not
sure about that but I can't unlock that
so there might be a way in through this
maintenance panel but I'm not 100% sure
Oh what oh oh where are we now
okay well this oh okay
hi stashing the halls by the escape pods
no time to rig a drop good luck why is
your head glued oh okay I don't know who
did that but did you do it to yourself
did you do it to yourself
a horrible way to go uh Kennedy turned
his back on intervention ISM oh yeah
that's right that's the book where
alternate history misty alternate
history took a different turn what is
that down there there's something down
there
oh is it worth getting leverage to oh I
don't know I've got a lot of neuro I've
got 17 holy Sh um keys sure I'll get it
I meant to spend that on like you know
special neuro mods but apparently not ha
boesky uh-huh are you ah exactly what I
needed exactly what I needed
okay so that's the security office key
there's something up here oh oh oh
one-way maintenance access oh it all
makes sense okay skadoodle II do all
right so we go through here and
hopefully grab a bunch of good [ __ ] ah
that's sweet good [ __ ] and then maybe
we'll be able to open oh yes oh I I hit
the wrong number but yes oh yes please
that was worth the neural mods then
hello fix Thank You engineer operator
you are a delight when we have here all
right life support engineer Jeanne
ferry's last known duty was to repair
life support related to machinery and
power plan in addition she has one
remaining keycard air filtration control
please find her ASAP let's see I'm aware
that you made repeated attempts to
requisition a shotgun a weapon that is
clearly outside your duty description
that you didn't come to me first with
this first is unfortunate you've been a
dedicated officer so I'm not jumping to
any conclusions but as a precaution your
access to the safe and the life support
security station has been revoked until
we sort this out I been there album this
job can be stressful and one for my back
on you but I have to follow procedures
I'll contact you shortly to set up a
meeting Weber I know you think I screwed
you over but I'm just doing my job what
am I supposed to do you tell me you're
having nightmares and feel compelled to
hide out well that's fine but when you
say you want to find a bunker stock it
with supplies and get your hands on a
shotgun not cool we were getting along
so well but I have to I guess we have to
be all business from now on
uh something about an active evacuation
hmm I don't know okay but what's there
another utility maybe - just an area map
I need to get through that door I guess
I haven't tried the door so that's my
fault but may I didn't think that the
door was open because it seemed to be
locked main lift is offline still
because I haven't done that yet I should
have done that first damn and I don't
even know how I'm gonna be able to get
back there now alright but at least I
can take this thing with me and set it
up in a place where it can probably
shoot some of these [ __ ] maybe right
here will be good why is there radiation
here [ __ ] oh hi what what am I
I can I shoot this goddamn guy where's
my gun where's my gun why don't you oh
my god are you kidding me
Jesus the [ __ ] man Oh seasons hello oh
you're still there nope nope nope I just
I just locked you down I just did where
are you
oh this getting on the nerves that's
getting on my nerves that's all much do
Street a lotta plot a small space
alright fine trance makes me
thank you okay
what did I throw that is instead of pent
up throw in store geez
alright fine things are [ __ ] with me
okay so there's a lot of lightning
coming from over there but it's all from
that same conduit panel so lock that
down and you think there are no service
requests anybody there I have no idea
looks like I can't get in there there is
some way to get in here which is always
weird hello this might sound strange
coming from me but I admire what you did
you didn't have to help chief Eleazar
and her people in the cargo bay
especially considering well considering
you intend to destroy the station
you gave them some hope even if it's
brief okay you don't know that you don't
know me cuz I'm not you and you're not
me and we don't know each other that
well we know each other a little bit but
not that well okay so I need to go the
reactor control room for something about
life is poor wait oh shut up there for a
second I got think okay so I can't get
back to the lobby until I go up to the
Arboretum and then I am able to get
through there so let me see what's in
here first I don't I don't think it's
where I need to go but I just want to
see come on hurry up I'm clean not
really I'm pretty sweaty sealed in this
rubber suit here whoa that sounds like
someone's going funky over there oh yeah
someone's definitely funky in here oh
you're on the ground are you disabled
then think your black glove slap
Wow okay oh yeah UNK okay
wait what's my status what my heart
rates up does it even mean let me see
you move this habu ski I can fight
that's not just leverage that's like
psychic powers there that's that's more
than what you get going on
Oh where's this ah okay maybe I
shouldn't be in here
zips up a little bit about okay more
specimens required yeah I get that I
need to figure out how those things are
why am I stuck here okay I guess I'll
just die right there we go then a whole
lot of something scared in ski get glorp
t' all right that's enough to our pitch
okay cool here we go to the control room
nuff skedaddling right under ah I saw
that sorry
oh yeah see you know know
skadoosh woman get down whoa clap thank
you for the spare parts I need him real
bad escape pods yeah that is weird that
all of the escape pods suddenly died why
would that be you know why would that be
huh bunk bunk yeah turn it are we gonna
we gonna we gonna go after hold on no
one cuz you're gonna die that's right
thanks buddy first out of turrets has
been any sort of good can you open there
we go I thought I thought for a second I
was locked out of there because there
was gonna be a dummy all right whoa okay
come at me bro
lemme oh wow can you hit that from where
you are
oh yeah he's not gonna stay locked down
forever come on come on come on come on
oh come on there we go live live live
laughs look at me not him
Oh too bad for you Oh Oh officer Joe
this is chief fellows oh yeah here chief
how can I help you I need you to report
to deep storage and get chief so to
reactivate the tracker on grant Lockwood
HRD activated it as part of
determination but we don't have a record
of him on the departing shuttle I want
to know where he is and escort him where
he needs to go on it chief
why has everyone dead in here that's
really weird why is everyone dead in
here today
future us we are not calling ourselves
that today I was able to convince my
beautiful but stubborn partner too
stubborn to stay in bed and not report
for an extra shift and this is the
reward I get this is so weird all of
these are here where they stopped by the
Typhon or where they stopped by
something else because every single one
of these is still in the bay and
admittedly there are a lot of dead
bodies but I don't know I just
I smell something why is this one need
repair three what's in that boat what's
what's in there yeah what's in there
come on show me show me
stop jittering oh really yeah that's how
you got to do that oh yeah okay I didn't
want to go in there anyway that was a
bunch of [ __ ] okay good to know I
find them but we got what we needed it
at least we got something that we needed
that guys still gonna be in there for a
while so let's carry on back to the main
objective she's sorry people want to
take with me and so many questions
unanswered like why is everyone dead
why is everyone dead why does everyone
need to be dead
all right so also there was the answer
or the question of the hell is going on
air huh what's going on here can i hack
this uh it's just about my hacking grade
I I could always get better hacking
which is something that is on my mind
yeah I'm gonna go for that I've got so
many neurons as it is I might as well go
for this
alright let's hack it up I've never done
the level three before boo you know
first time for everything
let's go fast I've picked the wrong
direction denied ow ow not today
come on you whoa this is about the worst
performance I could ever hope for but
there's so much time on a level three oh
that was easy
I'm so easy alright hey I got a heal up
once there was gonna be a dude here oh
good
lots of spare parts Oh in neuro mods it
was so worth it oh there was so worth it
then you spend neuromas to get neuro
months not equivalent but you know good
enough oh that's it so two bottles oh I
didn't know that oh I just damaged this
goddamn turret Oh Frick you I don't want
to waste all my spare parts but okay
your transfer uniform has been designed
for your safety even comfort I already
read one of these I think shells nothing
there player no nothing there this all
right this would be good enough is that
okay just one more thing there I'm gonna
take this thing out and I'm up station
it right over here I guess cool soup no
don't hack it I don't want you don't
hack it I don't need to hack it why
would I need to hack this what it's
already on my side why would I need to
hack this one jeez it's so stupid
there's no way to back out of a hack you
got it you got to finish it up all the
way double rainbow or can you just
deploy and be cool and not kill me
I see I see a dude over there that's
gonna get a little Jew
oh no tournament shooter
oh all right so I'm a tried this
disruptor stun gun I know it's probably
not gonna do a lot to tie flan but it's
gonna do some good me those noises going
on over here what is noise what what you
say what oh hi oh so you're like a
bigger one of those dudes alrighty then
[ __ ] I'm gonna take a look at this one
because this seems weird no that's not
what I wanted want the research on that
alright whatever it's fine go the other
way that way is not welcoming to me oh
ah I missed it well these they got my
back that's awfully handy
alright carrying on whatever the hell is
over here sweet oh why can I skip oh
what's going on their corrupted device
say whoa okay so there's a techno path
which is the thing in the other room
that's interrupting that so there's
gotta be a way to get in there I could
force it over with leverage but it looks
like there's a way up as it stands
should be oh oh oh okay I'm halfway up
I'm a little more up I've got the mad
UPS oh I can't make that jump but can
put some goop there and hope I hope I
hit this target cuz if I don't I'm gonna
fall I'm gonna fall a long way
for there we go okay made it nailed it
okay it maintenance hatch open all right
flashlights on what do we got wires
steal all the valuable electronics out
of the panel's in these bins what does
it matter
it's all about me right okay so I got to
get rid of that thing not sure how
that's gonna happen because that turd is
definitely hacked and if I get any more
turds in here I that they're gonna be
hacked to so it's all broken all across
the board so this is gonna be mono e
mono a it's gonna be mono e mono cuz I
can do mono e mono I can do it if I save
first but and also if I repair my suit
first cuz that's important to chunk and
to chunk you know I'm gonna do that and
then also I'm going to do no I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna do this eat a
few of these and now I'm good but if
you're techno then this disrupter gun
should do a whole big of a number on you
that's also I have this Q beam I got
this thing is this gonna do something to
you let me upgrade it just in case cuz
you know I've never really had a lot of
use for it so let me just upgrade that
bad boy ah this seems important okay
uh-huh uh-huh okay and then I'll upgrade
this thing cuz why not power sure stun
and amplifies damage to robotic targets
that seems like something that's gonna
be useful here you know what I'm gonna
use since I promised it I'm gonna use a
little little stabby here skittish
oh that's what I do oh I no idea
oh okay
what the [ __ ] is happening oh hey oh
yeah your oh boy so I need to be real
close to this guy okay it's fine it's
fine it's fine
what's this I'm in fireman fire I'm in
fire whoa I was in fire cuz a you
[ __ ]
I'll meet you as am o disabled forever
okay that guy was a bit of a son of a
[ __ ] but not too bad when you use the
right weapon about it who'da thunk it
would have been so simple as that oh not
me not me certainly not all of you guys
been shouting it at me thus far but
that's okay let's get a husky okay too
far too fast nothing there so that's now
open and I bet I can go further now so
that is all very good very very very
good so with that being very good I can
go recycle my [ __ ] unless I need to
turn them ah oh I thought the power was
off of that bad boy skadoosh and
skadoosh
you are a cool little gun I had 90
that's awesome okay and with that I am
all out of time for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you enjoyed it I did I know I messed up
a few times here and there but hey we're
making it through just fine so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]